hi there steve coffin here uh i'm going
to continue with those um
videos uh which relate to stephen
covey's uh seven habits of highly
effective people but first i want to
announce
that i'm going to do a webinar
on learning spanish which i'm going to
call the you know 12 tips
for learning spanish in fact i'm going
to do two webinars each one is going to
have 12 tips so you're going to get a
total of 24
it might even be 25.
tips on learning spanish
it's going to be this saturday
and it's at 10 a.m 10 00 in the morning
pacific standard time
and there'll be complete explanations in
the description to this video
so you're certainly welcome to
participate
uh
and i will speak for about half an hour
and thereafter i will turn it over to
questions
spanish now i hope to do a similar
series of two videos
uh
for other languages maybe after spanish
i'll do french or i'll do japanese i
don't know yet
uh i'll learn as i go along
because
in so many ways languages are very much
alike
languages have to express the same
concepts
and they do them in somewhat different
ways
uh it's not quite like that the opening
quotation
for uh tolstoy's anna karenina where he
says that
happy families
are alike are happy in the same way i
can't remember exactly
happy families are alike are happy in
the same way but unhappy families are
unhappy for their own different reasons
languages are overwhelmingly alike but
they all have little idiosyncrasies but
essentially
having learned now
more or less you know 13 14 15 languages
i'm struck by the similarities and i
think sometimes a person who isn't used
to learning languages may be overwhelmed
when they first start to learn start to
learn the language so i'm hoping that
this video of mine might help people
spanish you know i can't tell you how
much
happiness and joy i've had from spanish
i was recently in in mexico although
most of my experience has been in spain
lovely country color music pleasant
friendly people and lots of history and
of course i like to read
and the thing about spanish is it's
relatively easy to read because it's
spelled the way it's pronounced and
here's a book la idea de nuestro
patrimonio historico e cultural
very interesting book
where you become familiar with the sort
of mix of indio and spanish and so forth
in the history of mexico
i can't say that i've read this book but
i've read parts of it i've listened to
parts of it
it tends to my mind gets a bit
repetitious after a while
um
where are we here here one of the recent
novels that i read recent a few years
ago la sombra del biento which takes
place in barcelona which i first visited
in 1965
when franco was still in power
and of course i have read up lots on the
history of spain
traveled in spain and so forth so you
learn a language like spanish you become
acquainted with the history of the music
with the peoples of latin america of
spain it's a fabulous language so
join me
on saturday at 10 a.m pacific time
and you'll see the details here in the
description i look forward to seeing
some of you oh and the um webinar will
then also become a video and it'll be
available uh in in youtube thank you
see you then